I want to revisit with you taxation is
theft it's the little brother to
taxation is slavery that we sometimes
hear from Republicans and right-wingers
a new congresswoman a republican of
course Anna Paulina Luna pulled out
taxation is theft yesterday when being
interviewed on Fox Business by Neil
Cavuto let's listen and then discuss the
endless bottomless absurdity of this
silly claim that some Republicans like
to make I'm not going to say that I want
to cut defense spending but I will say
that I think it's important that we are
looking to make sure that we are getting
the best deal especially on some of the
stuff that we're spending money on so I
think that we need to have those
discussions but more or less what I've
heard in some of these negotiations is
we're talking about programs that aren't
going to the Necessities that we the
American people need I.E protections I'm
talking about some of these woke
ideology these funded programs and for
example these uh these salaries for
these additional weaponized 87 000 IRS
agents which you saw we tried to pass
yet the Senate and even the Biden White
House is pushing back on sir I say
taxation is theft and I don't want any
more IRS agents than you probably do
so wait
I I'm going to restrict this segment to
taxation it's theft because it's it's
interesting okay so first of all Anna
Paulina Luna's salary
um is paid by taxes so if you really
believe taxation is theft then you
should be refusing your salary you
should reject such an ill-gotten and
stolen salary if you actually believe
that taxes are theft because you're
being paid with stolen money sort of
makes you an accessory to the theft
that's number one she's not rejecting
her salary that I'm aware of but let's
talk about taxationist theft taxation is
theft every once in a while rears its
ugly head usually among libertarian
circles but sometimes among reactionary
Maga as well
taxation is not theft in a number of
different ways first of all
nobody is forcing you to pay taxes in
the sense that you have the option to
work or not to work don't want to pay
taxes don't work oh but then how would I
fund my life well you have a choice
secondly if you believe that the
taxation system in the United States is
theft you can try to go to a different
country that might have a different
system what you might find is that the
countries in which you can get away with
paying no taxes aren't places you
probably want to live now you might say
well David every country has taxes so
well your if your argument is the
American government is stealing through
taxes you're free to try to go somewhere
else if the immigration law will allow
you and if the tax law is more favorable
to you number three you have decided to
be here in the sense that you either
immigrated here knowing that there are
taxes in the United States or your
parents immigrated here and then birthed
you
or your parents were born here and chose
not to leave and birthed you here into
the system where there is taxes so you
do have recourse your parents had
recourse there are options here and then
number four you can also Lobby to get
elected officials who agree that
taxation is theft and if they get
elected they can try to eliminate taxes
so it's not theft and it's not slavery
now the bigger picture of course is
there is no way to have a civilized
society without taxes
anthropological research
and other sociological research tells us
that what usually they talk about 150
it's called the Dunbar number when you
get to 150 people organizing 150 people
you need some centralization and some
decisions that are made thinking of the
group as a collective if you don't you
have untenable situations that would
prevent Homo sapiens from ever advancing
to the point at which we are now ideas
of every road can be private and you
know you build a road and then you just
charge people to go on it and every road
is private or police is private and fire
is pride these things these things quite
literally do not work once you get
Beyond groups of 150 people
and so these folks are living in a
complete and total fantasy world usually
you don't hear straight up taxation it's
theft from elected officials in the
House of Representatives you hear it
more from activists you hear it more
from anti-tax groups or libertarian
groups but to straight up hear taxation
is theft from someone in a position of
power like this really shows us the
degree of radicalization in the current
Republican Congress and it is very very
scary
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us including ones that
harm our health fume is a natural
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors fumes new
version 2 model is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap that's fun to fidget
with its fume's goal to make switching
easy or even enjoyable they have
thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below